انا نوره اعيش في مستوطنه كديم اربعه انا
ام لاربعه اطفال اصغرهم طفله عمرها سنه
واحده واكبرهم عمره 13 عاما اعيش هنا منذ
حوالي اربع سنوات انا قلقه من تدهور صحتي
وصحه اولادي وزوجي وباقي افراد مجتمعي من
ان تصبح الاوضاع سيئه في القريب العاجل
نحن بالفعل نشاهد بعض الاعراض بسبب حرق
النفايات الاناء نعاني من امراض تتعلق
بجهاز التنفسي وهي على شكل نوبات ولكن نحن
ايضا خائفون انه في خلال سنوات قليله سنرى
امراضا مثل السرطان نحن خائفون واعتقد ان
الفلسطينيين في القرى المجاوره ايضا
خائفون من نفس الاعراض على اولادهم لا
يوجد هنالك قضيه سياسيه في توفير الهواء
النقي كل مره يذهب اولادي للخارج يعانون
من مشاكل تنفسيه ويتعاطون دواء الفينتولين
الذي يحتاجونه بشده نعطيهم خمسا وسته مرات
في اليوم فقط ليتمكنوا من التنفس وليفهم
اصحاب القرار ان ديمومه الحياه تعتمد على
الهواء النقي